let's go to the 401 0 area code caller
from for10 go ahead we can barely hear
you so let's change from Maryland I'm
sorry go ahead
Dina from Maryland okay I'm still not
getting that name you're we're not on
skiing it beat it beat it or whatever
all right
yeah well yeah I just want a question
you said that um you were going to
include more shows this year well what
we're doing is we're we're growing our
fundraising base so that when we go on
vacation we can have a rotating cast of
staff so that we can continue addressing
new shows yeah yeah but I had a question
like Pat Pat host the show one time I'm
sorry you're saying Ken are you ever
gonna let patch it lo the show that's
not a host Pat's a producer I know I'm
gonna say it Pat not a material
ask Pat I think that would do a pretty
good job I'm just asking
would you rather host or produce I would
rather produce the show I think yeah and
you've also probably thrown that this
would be part of my power play to take
over the David Pakman show so I don't
think I'm gonna be guest hosting anytime
soon right how does that sound
Oh material no no I don't want to
replace you without Dave thank you I
appreciate that
all right okay thanks very much for the
call
interesting day interesting day on the
phones very interesting